for millions the hit television drama
peaky blinders maybe a glimpse into the
culture trials and tribulations of life
in interwar birmingham not so though for
one outraged academic writing for the
Journal of popular television
according to George S lock washed honest
a British PhD holder in America peaky
blinders is really about and I quote
nostalgia for nationalism enacted within
displays of extreme aggression as well
as promoting regressive masculine ideals
specifically British lad culture so let
me get this straight
dr. lark Walsh wants the world of
working-class interwar Birmingham to
reflect her current and rather
privileged social and political biases
no art should not be expected to be
political propaganda the best works of
art are usually raw depictions of
certain climates peaky blinders as the
show's creators have told us reflects
the corrosive and brutalizing effects of
war on masculinity and the exploitation
during war of the working classes by the
establishment the establishment you know
those people with elevated titles in
distant ivory towers perhaps like dr.
George S luck moves from the University
of Texas
let's hear what the peaky blinders
producers say in just a moment but I'm
conscious Majid some folk are watching
this they'll be aware of the show but
they don't know a great deal about just
a bit more explaining before it's made
and it's about soldiers returned from
fighting in World War one and they are
as I've mentioned brutalized by the
effects of war but there are a family a
gypsy family a traveller family were
based in Berlin in the shabi family and
it's about how they turn their
experiences of war towards a life of
effectively crime and gangsterism to
progress through the social hierarchies
of of England as it was at the time and
so innocence you know they're struggling
against snobs in London who look down I
mean it touches too many themes today
whether it's class whether it's you know
wealth versus inequality whether it's
racism whether it's for example the
cities outside of London in decline
it speaks to all of those things which
is why I think it's so relevant yeah and
white struck a chord and I think what
the show does so well I love that show I
think number one it really authentically
depicts just how limited the options
were for men like that during that
period in British history and also
clearly George wherever her name is
professor god bless her in Texas last
thing Nick the name itself peaky
blinders it's based on a real true life
crime gang that did exist in Birmingham
they used to wear flat caps with the
peaks and hence the name peaky blinders
this is what the producers say the story
of peaky blinders invites viewers to
consider the effect of violence on men
the terrible and long-lasting constant
consequences on both and women and men
and women of gang violence poverty and
most
of all armed conflict the most disturbs
me about dr. George doesn't seem too
much and actually what she seems to be
most concerned about and here's the
other part of the quote that you gave
she says in the current socio-political
environment associated concerns about
the prevalence of toxic masculinity such
presentations no longer feel safe we
confined to fantasy now toxic max
masculinity and fantasy I know a show
where there is ritual assassination
child violence beheading girl-on-girl
sex boy and boy sex dwarf on violent
individuals in the West who killed
everybody this lady just doesn't seem to
know what most people the men in that
show wimps because the women are so
powerful so everything you've described
University in Texas but I don't really
understand what it's got to do with the
University in Texas she's British but
she's lecturing there but I just think
it's this whole over offended culture
people keep constantly getting offended
on other people's behalf and you know do
men really watch those kind of programs
and think for themselves I know what I
want to do
can we put anything really not TV same
people seek the fence and I think you're
onto something there but do we not have
certain we do already have a set of
framework and regulations and I think
the smart people in this and this lady
doesn't seem to me one amongst those are
saying that what we're doing is we're
normalizing a certain kind of attitude
towards women yeah and we're making
violence against women not as not as
horrible and unusual smidgen of a point
here
I think person is that what she's doing
is making that important point feel a
bit ridiculous this is what phoebe walla
bridge who's a writer and an actor had
to say she said i think people are
slightly exhausted by seeing women being
brutalized on screen
we're being allowed to see women on
slabs the whole time and being beaten up
in some ways that's important to see
because it shows the brutality against
women seeing women being violent the
flip side of that is refreshing and
oddly empowering well we've got to
decide which it is haven't we so we're
now going to say it's okay what we do
I'm thinking in 2016 Academy Award four
out of the eight films which were
nominated featured the rape of a woman
or a child something step back and look
at it again on these stats and women and
depictions of violence on women on
television screens Germaine Greer makes
a good point insights survey is actually
done to demonstrate and back up the
point but actually it's primarily women
who are demanding the violence against
women on television for consumption it's
it's it's an interesting
I think that's nonsense the novel form
was a form invented pretty much for
women to read so I think the idea that
somehow women are demanding this is just
silly women perhaps watch thrillers and
detective stories is proportionately the
problem is that what we're producing
though our crime stories and series that
depend on a level of violence and shock
would not have been the case do you want
a committee over the Academy Award that
says I'm terrorists or there's too many
violence I mean in the sentences
producers and writers to see what is
being done in aggregate because every
individual producer or writer thinks my
show dear anyone like it but with they
were to see that what's happened is the
aggregate and that comes from